ich fang sozusagen mit schwerem herzen
an denn ich bin heute den ganzen tag
schon in gedanken bei meinen kollegen
paul ronzheimer in kabul paul ist
dorthin gereist um für uns für sie
darüber zu berichten was in afghanistan
wirklich passiert das hat heute den
ganzen tag bei bild live getan und dann
ist etwas ganz ganz unglaubliches
passiert die amerikanische armee hat ihn
aufgefordert naja man kann eigentlich
sagen gezwungen das land zu verlassen
man will dort offensichtlich keine
journalisten die neutral berichten paul
ist immer noch da und wir versuchen
jetzt mal zu erreichen paul kannst du
uns in afghanistan hören
[Musik]
hören ich bin immer noch hier auf dem
rollfeld wollen wir dass soldaten mit
irgendwas die lasse ich hier nicht mehr
richtig raus ich bin hier so mehr oder
weniger abschieben und wartete darauf
dass ich in die maschine richtung doha
gestutzt werden auch mit anderen
flüchtlingen
[Musik]
paul erzähl uns von den geschehnissen am
heutigen nachmittag ich glaube du hast
schon viel erlebt den krisengebieten
aber dass auch noch nicht
nein so etwas habe ich noch nicht erlebt
klaus ist war so dass wir angekommen
sind dafür der maschine auf papa das war
die einzige möglichkeit mitzumachen
betrieb keine die waschmaschinen märz
gehabt und es rettet versetzt und dann
hat das us-militär uns gesagt am
vormittag ja ihr könnt dann
aussagen vom militär sind alt und
innenstadt das wurde dann zurückgenommen
am nachmittag und uns wurde verboten
dieses feld verlassen offenbar war das
eine entscheidung des generals ist sogar
dass der us aussenminister mit
gesprochen hat am ende ging es um 11
turna listen die er zusammen mit mir in
einem flieger gesteckt werden sollen
zurück nach doha wir werden nicht mehr
berichten können und das us-militär
verbietet und hier das gelände zu
verlassen man muss sich das so
vorstellen klaus natürlich ist es
gefährlich hier raus die stadt vorbei an
die taliban check points aber das ist
mein job das mach ich fertig sehr vielen
jahren und es ist genau auf welche
gefahren wird einlassen was das us
militär jetzt vorschreiben will was zu
gefährlich ist so etwas habe ich noch
nie was ist dein wasser neuer eindruck
was da dahinter steckt will man keine
neutrale berichterstattung will man
nicht bilder haben und berichte haben
wie damals in vietnam was ist der grund
ich glaube die usa sind völlig
überfordert die massen doch film doch
heute wieder zehntausende toren brüssels
mauern man ist erfordert von der zahl
der menschen sie waren doch evakuieren
und ich nehme das auch so was zwischen
den soldaten dass sie eigentlich ein
schlechtes gewissen aber schlechtes
gewissen was hier eigentlich passiert
ist dass so viele menschen den usa
gestoppt ist soll dafür gefallen sind
für dich und dass sie so viele menschen
zurücklassen und das denke ich immer
nicht besonders berichtet sehen und wo
man sozialisten schockiert zu sein dann
stoppt man sie das ist aber etwas was
ich niemals vom land of the free von den
amerikanern erwartet hätte dass die uns
journalisten die ja objektiv ihr ausland
berichten wollen dass ich eben super
haben müssen in die stadt holt dass man
uns da ein schwert und jetzt
wir hören dir gebannt zu paul und wissen
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht wohin mit
unseren gefühlen sowas habe ich auch in
40 jahren journalismus nicht erlebt
erzählt uns kurz noch wie geht es jetzt
mit dir weiter wann geht der flieger
keiner weiß genau wann der flieger geht
es gibt mal wieder neue informationen
das wurde war oft dass es halt in
notwehr gegen die ganzen tag und danach
ein anderer vielleicht klappt doch und
ihr könnt was unterschreiben auf eigenes
risiko tatsächlich
von einem soldaten dass der us
außenminister und der
us-verteidigungsminister wird
entschieden hätten an dieser frage was
ich schon absurd findet darüber auf
stall ist wie ihr seid ist oder nicht
also wir warten jetzt dass es eigentlich
die vierte nacht klausel der ich schlafe
die erste war die kanzlei am tag die
zweite war die anreise die dritte waren
der maschine von katar hier nach kabul
und jetzt ist die vierte nacht also ich
hoffe dass ich irgendwann mal schlafen
kann aber natürlich werden wir weiter
berichten das wünschen wir dir dass du
ein bisschen zur ruhe kommst pass auf
dich auf und wir sind gespannt auf alles
was du noch bericht ist und diskutieren
jetzt hier haben jede menge zu
diskutieren danke nach kabul
ja irgendwie bleibt dann wirklich spucke
weg oder nah ist sehr verwunderlich was
da gerade passiert
und ich meine jetzt macht es ja auf
eigenes risiko
dass also ich glaube schon dass die
amerikaner das zu verheimlichen haben
und aber wäre ein bisschen paul
ronzheimer in seinen reportagen verfolgt
ich also ich sehe den erst indoor wenn
er wirklich auch mit der maschine oder
ausgeflogen wird bis dahin ist noch ein
langer weg oder denn der sitzt mit der
nächsten maschine und kommt ja wieder
zurück also das ist also es ist ja noch
bis oder ich frage mich was kann der
nächste woche machen ich meine nächste
woche mir die amerikaner gesagt als sie
abziehen werden kann er dann wieder frei
einreisen also wird spannend werden also
für mich ist jetzt wirklich was mich
dann wirklich bewegt ist was bedeutet
das für die menschen die jetzt noch in
kabul in afghanistan sind und die nicht
mehr ausreisen können die nicht mehr
ausgeflogen werden können wie wir hören
wie wir gestern noch vom
außenministerium maß gehört haben sind
das ja noch womöglich mehrere hundert
deutsche und sehr sehr sehr sehr viele
tausend sogenannte ortskräfte die uns
geholfen haben die sind dann den taliban
schutzlos ausgeliefert mir macht das
angst und ich bin wirklich wirklich
wirklich wütend auch auf unsere
regierung das ist so weit kommen lassen
also paul ist ja nur dass gerade auch
gesagt ja sehr erfahren in diesen
situationen aber das was er uns
geschildert hat ist wirklich
außergewöhnlich und man kann nur die
daumen drücken dass er da natürlich auch
jetzt herauskommt aber bemerkenswert ist
ja wirklich dass das land und paul hat
ja auch gesagt will end of the free bei
der beim kampf gegen terror
natürlich auch journalisten mitgemacht
genommen hat embedded journalists die
durften dabei sein die waren dabei haben
soldaten auch begleitet beim kampf gegen
den terror wie ein land befreit werden
sollte also demokratie nach afghanistan
zu bringen und es ist dann schon
bezeichnet irgendwie das ein land bei
der kapitulation gegen den terror dann
sagt er und darüber dürft ihr nicht mehr
berichten dass wir nicht beschämen
deutet ja auch irgendwie dass sie wissen
was für bilder da sozusagen entstehen
werden von von von toten von menschen
die in ausnahmesituationen sind von
angst von kindern von einige haben wir
ja heute schon gesehen dass alles nicht
mehr zuzulassen bedeutet die welt
abzuschneiden von den der wirklichkeit
von der wahrheit die dort passiert es
ist etwas nordkoreanisches
ich heute gefragt er sich das heute
mittag gesehen hat dass paul und anderen
journalisten raus aus dem land ich saß
ein abend bevor die führung ist noch mit
ihm im journalistenclub auf einmal kam
nächster halt die nachricht dass er
pflegt ich war unglaublich stolz seine
kollegin zu sein dass er das auf sich
nimmt da hin zu reisen und jetzt soll er
plötzlich wieder zurückgeschickt werden
wir brauchen journalisten die dort
berichten und ich frag mich aber
vielleicht ist es auch ein bisschen dumm
meine frage aber ich frage mich warum
scheint angela merkel sich jetzt nicht
ein sie hat einen mutigen journalisten
aus deutschland der da ist weil es ja
gar nicht so und jetzt weil es hier gar
nicht so unrecht ist fertig von ihnen
sie muss doch auch stolz sein auf brauns
haben das mit deutschen journalisten
haben das waren also lieber ist jetzt
schon sehr also das jetzt angela merkel
vereinzelte journalisten unterstützt und
so stolz auf das haben wir jetzt bei
aller liebe aber
keine für alle journalisten einträge
sind der wunsch rausgeflogen sie könnte
jetzt ein statement machen sie findet
die pressefreiheit es wichtig dass die
journalisten dort sie muss aber nicht
mal erwähnen aber sie können jedoch für
alle journalisten ersten lanze brechen
aber ich meine jetzt auf die letzten
drei wochen jetzt noch so viele
statement rauszuhauen wir wirklich jedem
einzelnen
wir sind ja machen
ich glaube ganz ehrlich das ist angela
merkel auch ganz recht ist dass diese
bilder nicht entstehen von deutschen die
irgendwo in einem keller schutz suchen
von bildern in die straße szenen wo
vielleicht leute mit waffen hantieren
das ist ja glaube ich ganz recht dass
das nicht passiert denn es würde sie ja
weiter unter druck setzen denn angela
merkel hat er korrigiert mich
verantwortung für die deutschen
staatsbürger die dort in diese situation
geraten sind armin laschet hat heute
abend einen bemerkenswerten satz gesagt
wir kennen beide abend lassen doch es
konnte nur kurz ich hab schon wieder ist
jetzt der mann aber
heute noch mal gesagt in düsseldorf
heute abend dass er sich schon
vorstellen könnte und auch glaubt dass
die europäer alleine so eine
rettungsmission ohne die amerikaner
hinbekommen müssen und wohl auch könnten
also da hat er schon ein gewisser weise
glaube ich schon recht und wenn wir
jetzt über angela merkel reden und die
frage warum beschützt sie unseren
kollegen nicht muss man schon mal die
frage stellen warum sich angela merkel
dann nicht auch stärker ein und wird
beispielsweise bei boris johnson immer
nur darum dass die europäer eine
gemeinsame mission nochmal starten um
nämlich das zu verhindern was dann in
afghanistan passiert totaler terror
totales nordkorea und keine möglichkeit
mehr zu fliehen oder auch darüber zu
berichten
[Musik]